[Music]
president fest riots dear annie marie
sipkes
dear rupert wood distinguished guests
thank you very much for inviting me to
speak here at the
ftth conference it's a great pleasure to
welcome you all here in austria
the past two years since the kobit
outbreak
haven't been easy at all
so i'm very glad indeed to meet you here
all in person
and i'm also very happy that even a
delegation from the ukraine is attending
the conference
home schooling
working from home video conferencing
online shopping
e-government streaming films
deco with pandemic
has hugely increased demands on digital
infrastructures
we have seen the importance of digital
infrastructure rise
both
at work
and at home
and we all need the fast and stable
internet connection
and now the time has come to drive
forward the digital decade
which is only possible with a stable
broadband connection as you all know
austria has a very good coverage 91
of all households have at least 30
megabits per second and 50 percent
have already a gigabit connection
as the federal government
we have therefore set ourselves
ambitious goal
providing austria
with nationwide fixed
and mobile gigabit connection by 2030.
for this we have a concrete plan
first
at least 60 percent of austrian
households will be upgraded privately by
companies
the telecommunication act has created
investment friendly conditions here
austria completed the national
implementation of the european
electronic communications code in
october 2021
the relevant law the so-called tkg
includes a large number of provisions
covering all areas of telecommunications
one important part is
the creation of incentives for
investments in high-speed broadband
networks
because the demands on the electronic
communication networks are constantly
growing this has been achieved by
simplifying cooperation and
co-investment agreements and the
sector-specific laws
secondly
frequency allocations of mobile
communication
broad coverage obligations were imposed
on operators for the rapid
monetary
rollout in underserved areas in the
countryside
as a result
of these coverage obligations around
1
700 towns and villages will receive
nationwide high performance mobile
broadband coverage by 2023
this means that by 2030
we will be able to cover 80 percent of
these areas
thirdly
the remaining areas
there are for the remaining areas there
are public subsidies
since 2015
we have invested more than a billion
euros in broadband expansion reaching
1.1 million citizens and supporting a
rollout in nearly
400 towns and villages this has in turn
triggered investments of 2.5 billion
euros
with the new framework of the initiative
broadband austria 2030
a total
of 1.4 billion additional funds will be
available until 2026.
with our second so-called broadband
billion we will take a huge step to
achieve our goal
however
especially in the countryside expansion
is difficult and of course is no
expensive
that is why we are starting the
broadband turbo with the second
broadband billion
we can make even better use for
digitalization through good digital
infrastructure we can create equal
opportunities in the regions
you have to know that around 40 percent
of the austin population live in
non-urban areas
people should be free to choose where
they live
broadband expansion
is also crucial for an attractive
business location
if we want to remain competitive we must
invest in digital infrastructure
make austria even more livable
through digitalization
nevertheless
we all have to act together to reach our
ambitious goal of nationwide fixed and
mobile gigabit connection by 2030.
every euro
we invest in digital infrastructure
is investment in the future
in quality of life
and in competitiveness
i'm very much looking forward to my new
task of leading austria one further step
into the digitalized world thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you